in this video you're going to learn
everything you need to know about
youtube monetization in fact
i'm going to be revealing how much
youtube pays me
for 3 million views over the last
month we're also going to be talking
about how to join the youtube
partner program the five ways to earn
money payment methods and taxes like how
to actually collect the money
from google who owns youtube key terms
you need to know
and a new report that reveals how much
creators are earning currently
millions of creators are earning money
from the youtube partner program and
we're going to be touching on
alternative forms of revenue so if your
ambition
is to be able to work from home make a
living from your influence on youtube
bolt on extra streams of revenue to your
business as an entrepreneur
then you're going to want to buckle your
seat belt for this entire video
because it's power packed with lots of
important
information that you need to know if
you're serious about youtube and this
information
is coming directly from the source it's
coming from youtube
and it gets kind of complex so i'm going
to be breaking it down
so that you can understand it and apply
it to your channel
to not just grow faster but to make more
money
and hey if you're new to the channel my
name is sean cannell my passion is
helping you build
your influence with youtube i've built
multiple youtube channels and my passion
is helping
other people like some of our students
that you can see on screen here
get that silver play button monetize
their influence
and build a full-time business around
their youtube channel so click subscribe
if you haven't yet and today's episode
is all about
youtube monetization explained five ways
to earn money and how
youtube pays you now this is part of our
three-part series
part one we talked all about youtube
search and how youtube works
in part two we talked all about youtube
recommendations and once you got the
views going once you got that momentum
once you got the subscribers coming in
well then how do you monetize and so
this is how youtube works part three
all about monetization and today's
episode is brought to you
by our youtube starter kit and if you
haven't heard we are running a very
limited holiday special
where you can get 90 off the youtube
starter kit
if you haven't seen it's a digital asset
bundle that is full of powerful
resources like our youtube clarity
blueprint the 15 youtube title formulas
for getting views
51 money making video ideas guide which
is very important in case
you're not in the youtube partner
program yet 51 video ideas to jump start
your camera best cameras and video
equipment how to create
awesome thumbnails which has a training
of how we create thumbnails on think
media that has not been released
anywhere else
and we have a very special price of 37
that's over 90
off during the holidays so
tubestarterkit.com
is where you can learn more about that
and now let's get into the episode so
how do you get into the youtube partner
program well to apply for the youtube
partner program
you must meet check this out eligibility
thresholds
related to watch time and subscribers
you must fill out
an application and then youtube reviews
the application to ensure
that your channel has not run afoul of
youtube's monetization content and
copyright policies
policies only channels that meet
eligibility requirements
and thresholds and follow the guidelines
will be admitted to the program which
makes them eligible to receive
access to ads and other monetization
products so if you're excited to
actually
explain some of this crazy language
smash the like button because i'm going
to try to make this as clear and as
simple as possible in this video
but if you want the current update of
how monetization works
let's break it down so the minimum
eligibility requirements to join
is that you need to follow monetization
policies we're going to talk about that
but that's a collection of policies
there's a lot of
there's a lot of different ones and if
you're a youtube partner your agreement
includes
that you're in compliant with things
like copyright
things like youtube's terms of service
that you have advertiser friendly
content okay next
that you live in a country where the
youtube partner program is available now
in the description there's going to be a
series of links
the youtube partner program is available
in i think nearly a hundred countries
now
so you need to be living in in a country
where it's available you need to have
more than 4 000 public watch hours
that's
hours of your content consumed across
your whole channel within 12 months
and that's a rolling 12 months it's not
like ever it means it's always the last
12 months have you hit 4 000 watch hours
yet
and i i think it happened to me on one
of my smaller channels
i actually got booted out of the program
for not maintaining
my amount of watch time hours so you
have to make sure you hit that
you need at least 1 000 subscribers and
then you need to link
an adsense account and we're going to
continue to explain these things in
greater detail
now in the back of your youtube channel
you're going to see
that once you have accepted
the program terms once you have set up
your
google adsense account so the two
different things you need to set up is a
youtube channel
then you also need to set up a google
adsense account remember links in the
description to resources
once you've got your monetization
preferences set up
then your channel goes into a review
after you've hit the targets and so what
you'll see it looks different depending
on how updated
the back end of your youtube is it'll
say you need 1 000 to be reviewed and 4
000 to be reviewed so it'll count it up
now at the time of recording this i'm
recording it on our think marketing
youtube channel
on our coffee with kennel show and we
just got this channel
it's brand new this year and it took us
a few months to hit these targets we're
rolling the hours up uploading our video
podcast and doing live streams like i'm
recording
this one and we were just calculating
those hours
hit the subscribers and then eventually
we applied to
get reviewed it sometimes can take a
couple days
it could sometimes take weeks so that's
kind of the process and in the back end
of your youtube channel
you'll see where you are on that
journey so you also need to set up an
adsense account for your payments
so in addition to setting up
a youtube channel you need to set up an
ad
sense account and then later you will
connect
that adsense account to your youtube
channel and a cue a key thing here is
you really want to make sure you only
have
one adsense account they're very
passionate about this notice it says
duplicate adsense account created
through your youtube will not be
approved
and will be turned off for the
associated youtube channel
so let's summarize it how do you join
you need to make sure you start a
youtube channel
then you need to follow youtube policies
we're going to go deeper into those in
just a second
so this is where it gets into the idea
that just because you have a youtube
channel and even just because you're
getting your content viewed
if you don't rest inside of youtube's
good graces regarding your content
then you may not be approved for
monetization on a channel basis or on an
individual
video basis you got to live in a country
where the ypp the youtube partner
program is available
you have to reach the eligibility
thresholds 1 000 subscribers 4 000 hours
of watch time in the last 12 months
you then have to apply and get reviewed
and there's not a lot you can can do to
speed that up or not
besides maybe how advertiser friendly
your content is
how much content you've posted youtube
likes to say part of the reason of those
eligibility thresholds
is now they have something to review
they can see your brand they can see
your channel
they can see your thumbnails they can
get an idea of what your channel is
about so
if it becomes very quickly clear that
wow this this person
it's not really playing in like a
copyrighted content place
their topic and subject matter is really
aligned with advertiser guidelines
they've been putting out a lot of
consistent content there seems to be
good user engagement
those things could potentially get your
channel approved quicker
and let's say you're more borderline in
a gray area of the type of content you
create it might take longer
and again there's not a lot you can do
to control that review timeline period
and then number six you gotta set up an
adsense account
and then link your adsense account and
once you've done all these things you
could start collecting
uh money from youtube a couple things
that will help speed up
getting approved is you wanna enable
two-step verification for your google
account
which means you will protect your
account and your password so it's smart
you should have two two-step
verification everywhere
to prevent you or help you from getting
hacked make sure you only have
one adsense account and then once you
get accepted
then you can start building from
there if you get rejected from the
youtube partner program
and the reviewers found that a
significant portion of your channel
doesn't meet the policies and the
guidelines
you can reapply after 30 days so don't
worry if you get rejected
you can always re-apply and so um
let me know if you're getting value
towards the end of this video i'm going
to be answering
your questions and your frequently asked
questions so definitely stick around for
the entire video
and post your questions if you're here
live because we'll flush out anything
that's unclear
in this training all right next
what are youtube's monetization policies
that's the big question right
so a key eligibility requirement of the
ypp
is to follow monetization policies they
include community guidelines
terms of service and the google adsense
program policies that's quite a bit of
stuff right
so here's what you have you have
community guidelines terms of service
copyright google adsense policies and
advertiser friendly
policies now i've got good news for you
if you're already feeling a little
overwhelmed take a deep breath
and know that there are other ways to
earn money besides the ypp however
this also should not be super
overwhelming because
if you're just making good content
that's helping people and serving people
this shouldn't really cause you any
stress but youtube is a massive company
owned by google right that is actually
paying
millions of creators through this
program and when you sign up for this
you're in business
it's just like going to sign up for a
job and to get hired at a new job where
you're going to fill out like forms
and go through training and onboarding
so
they have they have legal
vulnerabilities
as a massive company they're in business
with you so that's why there's
all of this different policies and
whatnot so here's a couple clarity
points of what this
stuff is community guidelines um that
includes
spam and deceptive deceptive practices
are things that will get you disapproved
if you are impersonating somebody else
if you're linking to porn or malware
or deceptive content if you're running
scams
sensitive content anything that maybe
violates child safety
thumbnails with sensitive content that
maybe has like nudity or violence or
misleading thumbnails
um self-injury suicide this video will
probably get demonetized because of the
words i'm using
um violent and dangerous content cyber
bullying
regulated goods it could be illegal or
recreational drugs
firearms all of that kind of stuff if
your content is about that
you may not get your channel monetized
because you could be outside of the
community guidelines if you go
well this channel that does that kind of
stuff is monetized
and is part of the ypp well one they
might have limited ads being shown
or sometimes you might get your channel
uh approved
which is fine but maybe you talk about
one of those topics in a particular
video and that one video might get
demonetized
just like this one might get notice even
the words i was saying i said some words
just now about you know nudity like
youtube
might turn the monetization of this
video from green to yellow
because i'm talking about illegal drugs
and they're they're gonna hear those
types of things all the more depending
on what the visuals are in your video
and whatnot
and that's just your general community
guidelines i get it you might be like
why can't i just talk about whatever i
want and just have youtube pay me look
you're in business
they're the boss were technically the
employee
in terms of the ypp if they say jump we
say how
high unless you want to monetize in
other ways and we'll talk about that
but i think that is an important thing
to know now the terms of service are
just like
you probably do this with every software
you install every time you open up like
your phone your droid or your apple
and you just skip through 48 pages of
terms of service well yeah that's going
to be
your rights youtube's rights how they're
going to handle your information
so you have to sign off on that when you
sign up for a youtube channel and an
adsense account
lots of details in there we won't go
into it copyright
creators should be uploading videos that
they've
made themselves that you're authorized
for all the content in the video
that means you shouldn't upload videos
you didn't make or use content in your
video
that is copywritten like music or
copyrighted programs or tvs or video
made by other users
without necessary authorizations so
if you really want to be on the safe
side of ypp you want to avoid
copywritten content
now there's a whole segment of people
who use what's called fair use
to put compilations together gaming is
technically copyrighted but a lot of
gaming companies will allow
their content to be streamed because
they know it builds their brand others
have challenged that and it seems
weird but yet it's in their power to do
so there's movie review channels that
play clips of movies or photos of movies
talking about
recaps of shows or seasons so there's
ways to use copywritten content that's
the subject for another day
regarding fair use but you could get
into trouble
if your content is not your own and
again if you go you know
what you want to consider is you could
be building your channel hitting your
subscribers getting views
getting your hours and then your channel
might not be
approved depending on the type of
content on the channel
so if you're going to build a youtube
business around the the ypp you want to
think through
all of these things
and you can study more fair use uh if
you are creating certain types of
content
then of course google's adsense policies
now google adsense
is the ad platform that integrates
through the advertising that will play
on your videos so some of their policies
are like that you're not going to click
on your own ads
that you cannot tell your viewers to
click on your own ads or try to reward
hey we're doing a giveaway
you know if you click on whatever
um invalid click spam you know because
they don't want you to game the system
and that's kind of what those policies
are and then you've got your advertiser
friendly content guidelines
so if you check all the boxes you're
kind of within the community guidelines
and these overlap
a little bit with the advertiser
friendly guidelines but again this now
is up to
target whether they want to advertise on
your videos or whether
you know a baby clothing company or
any creator wants to like you know a
particular church or faith group may not
want to advertise
on a certain type of content so
if you want to be advertiser friendly
inappropriate language could cause
limited monetization or demonetization
and not getting approved violence adult
content shocking content
harmful and dangerous acts hateful
content incendiary or demeaning content
recreational drugs or drug related
content tobacco-related content
firearm content controversial issues and
sensitive events and adult themes in
family content i know
this is controversial and some people go
well i want to talk about the news i
want to talk about world events
and this is something that youtube
continually struggles with
this is why many news channels whether
it's on the right or the left
whether it's one of my favorite news
channels phil defranco
why he has created multiple other
revenue streams
because in order when you're talking
about the news
you might not be a channel about
recreational drugs but you might be
talking about
like i'm talking about it right now
right and this video might get
demonetized
therefore you have multiple other
streams of revenue
you don't have to worry too much this
you want to worry if
this is the theme of your channel but i
wouldn't worry too much about one-off
videos being monetized or not
because sometimes you just want to talk
about or need to talk about what you
need to talk about
but these are important information to
know at the end of the day this is the
youtube monetization policies
and so when you are in the good graces
of youtube
then things will go great for you in the
youtube partner program
and let me give you an example on our
channel think media
we're pretty advertiser friendly in fact
like almost completely i would think
completely
because we're talking about cameras how
to use a camera
we don't curse in the videos and
we don't use illegal drugs while filming
in the videos you know what i mean
so like it's it's it's pretty straight
and narrow now on the other side
depending on your content format these
are things you need to consider and
please do not unless actually if you
want to drop a comment and talk about
how mad you are please do
but you know at the end of the day they
go well this is
youtube's free will to let you in or not
so advertisers want certain types of
content and by the way there are certain
advertisers that actually maybe want
edgier content you know they don't mind
being on
certain types of content and youtube is
giving an environment where um that is
made possible
all right so the five ways to earn money
with the ypp you down with ypp
yeah you know me let me hit uh hit the
like button if you're getting value out
of this video so far
so number one advertising revenue we all
know this
when you watch an ad that plays at the
beginning of a video this is also
overlay ads a little banner or different
video ads display ads when you search
and there's ads at the top
channel memberships you can become a
member of certain channel if they set
that up
and you can collect money monthly for
someone to subscribe for like premium
content from you
for extra videos from you that are just
for members merchandise
shelf underneath your videos on our
think media channel right underneath the
video you can get
think hats think hoodies things like
that so people can
browse and buy merchandise super chat
and super stickers
if you're getting value out of this very
training you could drop a super chat you
could
do a super sticker messes gives you a
chance
to have your message highlighted and to
kind of be like a tip jar
to say hey sean grateful youtube premium
revenue this is interesting
because i pay for youtube premium this
is i pay so that i don't see any ads
sure it gives you access to like youtube
music don't really care i also pay for
spotify
um it gives you access to a few other
things one of my favorites is that you
can download your videos
and watch them offline in case back in
the day when i would fly all the time
i would take you know download a bunch
of videos so i could watch them on the
flight
but the big thing about youtube premium
revenue is you're skipping past
advertiser friendly content because
me i pay 10 11 12 bucks whatever it is
now a month
to be distributed between the content i
watch
because how do creators get paid when i
watch content because i don't see ads
when i'm logged in
on the channel that has youtube premium
revenue so they are going to distribute
a portion of that youtube
premium revenue to the creator that's a
part of the youtube
um monetization program the youtube
partner program
they're going to give them a portion of
my youtube red money
think about that no matter what kind of
content it is
meaning if it was non-advertiser
friendly i
am watching it and i've already paid
youtube for it so there's some
algorithmic way they distribute that
but that is a different kind of stream
and when you you'll see in your back-end
and your adsense
that uh this is something that will show
up
uh for you as a separate source of
revenue thanks so much for that super
chat and congrats on hitting 1000
subscribers
you're welcome for the advice
um hey uh so here's the requirements
ad revenue you got to be 18 years old or
have a legal guardian
older than 18 years of age who can
handle your payments via adsense
so how do these kids channels you know
how are they a part of
you know add the the ypp they have a
legal guardian
sign up for the adsense okay
next you got to create content that
meets advertiser friendly content
guidelines and we just described all the
different kind of
youtube policies now channel memberships
if you want to be able to invite people
into channel memberships you got to be
at least 18 years old and have more than
30 000 subscribers
and one thing to note is this stuff is
constantly updating and changing so
that's one reason why you definitely
want to hit subscribe
because you just want to have a constant
flow of information for when
maybe the subscriber amounts change it's
within youtube's free will and we're
going to be talking about a little bit
later how policies do change
and how there's updates so you need to
have more than 30 000 subscribers
for channel memberships merchandise
shelf you need to have
more than 10 000 subscribers super chats
you got to live in a country and reason
region where super chat is available
and then it would precede the fact that
you've got your channel approved to go
live which isn't hard to do but there
are some
you can actually start going live on
desktop
pretty easy and you can look that up on
how to do that
you could go live um on your mobile
phone i think you need a thousand
subscribers but once you do you're able
to get a super chat
like kg beauty within just drop thank
you so much
uh kg beauty appreciate you and so
though that's a super chat and how cool
you just saw five dollars
just came to uh the think marketing
channel much of love and appreciation
out of gratitude for this training in
some cases you might be
you know more of an entertainment more
than an education channel but that's a
way to earn revenue
through the youtube partner program and
then youtube premium revenue which is
content
create content watched by a viewer who
is a youtube premium subscriber
and remember that's going to bypass
that's not you know
dove soap advertising on the video it's
actually a portion of that
person's youtube premium membership
going to the creator that they want to
support that's one reason why i love
youtube premium membership
because it really is not only do you not
have to watch ads so it saves time but
it allows you to like directly interface
with the creators you watch most
that when you spend your time consuming
someone's content you're voting for them
even just with like the 11 or 12 bucks a
month that you pay to be a part of that
um and so those are the different
five ways now there's a sixth way it's
called brand connect
and once your channel reaches a certain
size this
shows up in the back end so like we
don't have this on our think marketing
channel we do on our think media channel
and this helps you get paid uh to
include brand content in your video
and um this you need to have a pretty
large channel i'm not sure the exact
number
numbers um and this is kind of a way to
do influencer marketing and brand deals
directly connected to youtube i believe
my friends benji and judy
almost exclusively do brand deals now
through this because it's just
they're in a good flow with it and so on
think media we're signed up and they
will email us
when there's opportunities and they do
not guarantee they'll email you
so in the meanwhile that is a way brand
deals can flow to us something media
but we've lately been working with
diltrucks and gvm
and epidemic sound and vid iq and
different people
just directly so think about that too
outside of the youtube partner program
outside of getting approved for brand
connect
as soon as you biz dev as soon as you
start to hustle and build those
relationships
build his targeted audience then you're
able to
um start taking advantage of that thanks
for the super chat grilling with coleman
the diaper fund i appreciate that my son
my son sean bradley kennel
is 10 weeks old at the time of recording
this super crazy new dad over here
so here's the fact you don't have to be
a part of the youtube partner program to
make money on youtube
i just want you to know that we're going
to go deeper and some information you
need to know
but your goal is to create multiple
revenue streams through other side
hustles and businesses
and you should do that either way even
if you are a part of the youtube partner
program
you don't want to become dependent on
just that one income
stream um and so your goal
like for example this happened recently
there was a youtube bug
that cut certain creators pay by 50 or
more and it was pretty crazy
because so people showed they were they
had money coming in every day 50 bucks a
day 150 a day and it just
zeroed out now youtube did not
acknowledge the problem or provide any
details
and it seemed to be remedied and
my point is not to go deep into this but
here's my mindset
my mindset is that at any time
youtube ad revenue could go away and
that i don't want to build
my business on youtube ad revenue
at this point and i'm going to reveal
some numbers to you in just a bit
it's the ypp is a very powerful program
that impacts what we're building at
think media on overall in our company
but again i'm just aware that if if for
some reason
we fell outside of advertiser friendly
guidelines you know it's like they're
like an at will employer they can do
what they want
so i also want to have income streams
that are within my
control so that is a huge mindset that i
want you to take on if you're serious
about doing this full-time you got to
build multiple streams
of revenue and think bigger and think
different and if you want help
doing that and you haven't watched our
free class at thinkmasterclass.com
it's brand new and updated for 2021 and
so
it's going to teach you other ways to
earn money outside of the youtube
partner program as well as how to get
views and subscribers and some of the
latest strategies for growth working
right now on youtube so again
thinkmasterclass.com and a summary of
all resources
in the youtube description below um
including that and the links and places
to sign up and all the stuff we're
talking about in this video which brings
us
to how do i get paid by youtube when i
earn money
how do i get paid so unless you're part
of a
mcn a multi-channel network then all
payments are going to be issued through
your adsense account now i don't
necessarily recommend being a part of an
mcn i've got friends who have niche
channels
meaning they have like 20 different
faceless channels and they usually run
those all through an
an mcn and then they get paid through
paypal from that mcn
that's getting a little complex but at
the end of the day when you work through
an mcn
they're dealing with like adsense in a
way or they're even dealing directly
with advertisers
and able to like sell ads on your videos
or however it works out and then they're
cutting you a check
for most of us we're gonna be just
signed up on adsense
so here's what it says in order to
receive your payments sign up into an
adsense
account and make sure you've resolved
all payment holds
so sometimes it's like you need to
update your social security number you
need to update your tax info you need to
make sure your address is verified
whatever and there's a reason they're
holding your payment once you've reached
your payment threshold and we'll talk
about that in a second
then they will cut you your money as
long as you're not suspended on your
channel for not being in compliance with
the policies
so there has been times when sometimes
people's money's been frozen or whatever
and there's been times where it's kind
of discouraging because it seems like
maybe the channel didn't do anything
wrong or there's times when the channel
got a little sketchy
and all of a sudden they violated
policies and things got interesting
so i know this cannot be like your
cortisol level you're like
this is stressing me out man there's
like how many is this a novel like
how this this training's longer than the
bible like what are we talking about
okay um you just want to kind of just
think that again if you're creating up
upping up content you're serving people
you're helping people you shouldn't
really run into this stuff but this is
just important information to know
so here's how you get paid number one
provide your tax information to google
adsense
now this is not required in all
locations so
that's something that um you want to
check out for your own region
then you confirm your personal
information you have to verify your
identity again not required in all
locations
but i think u.s canada australia
europe you're going to need to do that
verify your address as well
select your form of payment and then
meet the payment threshold
now here's how you confirm your personal
information
because personal identification numbers
are sent to a mailing address
so if you have a mailing address they
send a
pin number so now they know
that they that that is a real address
because a piece of
mail came to that address and you
entered that pin number
online got it and it's also important to
confirm the accuracy of your payment
address and your payee
name and let me just pause here because
every once in a while i get an objection
and someone's like
well wait a minute i like don't want
anyone to know my identity though
well then you're probably not i mean i
get it you might be able to go out
somewhere
like wait by the certain fence at six
a.m in the morning
to get you know to go do some work under
the table to get some cash
this is not that this is working with a
giant corporation
that like needs your identification
number needs you to have an address need
you to be a real person
and i and that's that's just what it is
so
you have to you know give them their
your name give them your information
just like most employers that are paying
or all employers that are paying taxes
are going to require your social
security number and all that kind of
stuff
you will become kind of like an employee
for google
who owns youtube all right so
you can change your payment address
change your payee name you're going to
verify your identity so depending on
location you need to verify your
identity your name your address your
date of birth
um you typically if you're required to
do this you typically won't be asked to
verify your address if you've verified
your identity
and youtube's always doing things like
maybe they'll send certain pins to your
phone
to to confirm with the phone number and
if your phone number is you know
you might be able to get this done
really quick or you might have to jump
through some hoops and have them mail
you like a piece of paper
so verifying your address when your
earnings reach a certain threshold
they'll mail you a pin number in most
cases wait
two to three weeks for that to arrive
and then you'll enter that
pin number and you'll be able to that'll
verify your address
now you can start collecting money let's
say you get approved for the ypp
and your money your channel is making
money you actually
don't need to be too afraid that you're
not going to be able to get that money
even if it just keeps
keeps building up it may just be sitting
there
until you check all of these boxes cross
all your t's dot all your eyes
and then all the money will be released
to you at once so maybe you're like
shoot my money's just been sitting
in my google adsense but i haven't
verified my address i haven't selected
my form of payment
as soon as you get that all dialed that
money should be released to you
next when you reach a certain payment
threshold
you then select your form of payment
there may be several
for payment forms available to you and
we'll cover those in a second
and usually when it comes to your
threshold
for example it could be different
depending on where you live but it's
probably like a hundred dollars
so if your current balance reaches 100
during january
let's say and you've completed all of
these steps then you'll
issue the payment to you at the end of
february this is important to know
so if you're like desperate to pay your
next bill with rent
this is not the strategy for you if
you're just getting started
you should be thinking about earning
money in other ways because you can see
this could take
weeks get it approved months to get it
all set up
for the checks to come through plus you
got to get the views and the
monetization to build up
so again let's also say you make 33 a
month
in the ypp once you're approved it might
take you a couple months before you hit
a payment threshold and then that will
actually be
released to you right so
that is how that breaks down now how can
i actually collect the money
from youtube which is google through
adsense so when you reach the threshold
you may be eligible for checks efts
electronic funds transfers
eft versus via single euro payments
area a sepa a repeata a wire transfer
these are some of the ways and again
we'll link resources
personally i have direct deposit set up
electronic funds transfer so every month
with the momentum we have now obviously
we hit the threshold every month
and the money just gets transferred into
my business bank account
um you may want to separate conversation
but eventually you may want to identify
your side business with separate
accounts even if you don't set up an llc
and this is not legal advice or business
structure advice but even if you don't
actually set up
an llc or an s corp or anything else you
may want to set up a separate bank
account and that way you can know how
much your side hustle's earning
and you could connect your amazon
affiliates
your what youtube partner program if if
someone
pays you the money goes in that account
so that way you actually maybe
know and on the one hand you're not
intermingling funds
so it might even help you later on taxes
for organization but even just for
organization
you direct all of your side hustle
income into a particular bank account
but regardless um that's how i do it the
other way is once your address is
approved they may actually mail you a
check
then you have to go to your bank and
deposit that check some people like
getting that check in the mail
i use electronic funds transfer
how much does youtube pay so now i'm
signed up for the ypp now i'm in the
program
youtube pays a rate between
point zero one cents and point zero
three cents for an
ad view now when you look in your
analytics you'll notice there's a
difference between a view in an
ad view the key is they're going to pay
for an ad view
not a view what are you talking about
sean well
ads don't always play right so you get
paid
when someone actually views an ad
so based on this article a youtuber can
make around 18
per 1000 ad views which comes out to
three to five dollars per 1000 video
views okay
and that's called what's what's called a
cpm
and and they say that cpms range
anywhere from one to five dollars
so a simple way to think about it is
again that for every
1000 views you get you might make two
dollars
and therefore if you got a million views
you'd make two thousand dollars
one thousand views two dollars a million
views two thousand dollars
now forbes estimates that top talent can
make
anywhere from five for every 1000 video
views five dollars
there's eventually what's called youtube
premium ads
which is reserved for like the elite
youtube channels
and they might make more because their
influence is considered to be greater
so the thing you need to know is that
this varies
it varies on your niche it varies on
where you live it varies
a lot on your audience how old your
audience is how much
buying power they have and this is a
conversation for another video
it also varies on engagement um some of
our top viewed videos
on think media i'll actually show you
some later
that are longer and have more engagement
earn more
it has to do with the topic of the
content it has to do with the niche
you're in so there's a lot of factors
so here's a couple key terms that you
need to know
one is cpm and rpm so cpm is the cost
per 1000 ad impressions
it stands for cost per mill i believe
and mill means a thousand
in like latin and so cpm is the cost per
1000 ad impressions before
youtube takes a revenue share and we're
going to explain youtube's revenue share
you are not getting all the money so rpm
is the total revenue after youtube's
revenue share
so the cpm is like what does it cost to
advertise
on this particular channel for example
if you have a channel that's all about
personal finance saving stocks and
investing
advertisers average advertising on a
channel may pay a lot more money because
of the audience that watches graham
stefan
talk about the stock market might be
kind of a more
affluent audience therefore they'll pay
more
if something is considered if you will
lower quality call it just cat videos
it's a random audience that's not super
focused it may be getting
millions and millions of views but it's
a ton of 13 year old kids
and it's a ton of people that just don't
really it's a different audience
so the cpm could be less than a dollar
on one channel and the cpm could be 30
on another channel so cpm is a number as
it says here that's more advertiser
focused
um it includes only video views from
videos that are monetized and it's
earnings before the revenue share
whereas rpm
is actually a number that they started
putting your back end
that's focused on you it's actually just
there to simplify things for you
to actually say how much money did you
actually make sean give me a break this
is the most
intellectual you know like this is a lot
of information bro
summarize it rpm like when you see your
rpm it's telling you
how much you're making and here's what
it also includes it includes
how much you're earning from ads after
youtube takes their cut
it includes also all the super chats
channel memberships
so it just kind of gives you a number of
how your channel
is performing it includes the total
number of views from your videos and
includes ones that did not monetize
so it actually cpm is focused on ads
actually
paying rpms saying you got a million
views a month and based on getting a
million views a month
you got people in channel memberships
you got people watching your videos
you got ads playing sometimes other
times let's just simplify it out of the
million views
here's how much you earned you went live
a bunch of times here's the super chats
it's just all views and activity final
money left over so rpm is their attempt
to
summarize it in this case and i've seen
rpm be used different in different
marketing settings
so here's think media in november 2020
playback based cpm 20 and 49 cents
that might shock you because if the
average cpm
is three to five dollars or even one
dollar
20 is freaking crazy why
think media is talking about tech tech
products
talking about business development
talking about
things like this which are much more
intellectual like
entrepreneurs watching like you creators
like you
that are this is not an entertaining cat
video you know what i mean like it's a
whole different mindset if you're here
so it's a higher cpm now that's also
notice how aggressive this is though
that's just the total
number before youtube took their cut my
rpm is like half that
see that so youtube's taken
i'll tell you the exact percentages in a
second but it's almost like youtube
takes half
now we don't get a ton of super chats
live stream wise on think media
um so that doesn't affect it we don't
have channel memberships so this is a
pretty raw
measure of simply ads and off of 3.4
million views total
that doesn't mean all the views were
monetized right or that ads played the
whole time
but in november on think media out of
three point four million views
we earned thirty thousand almost thirty
one thousand dollars
and it varies depends on the channel but
now you're seeing
an example what niche you pick
the quality of your content the quality
of the engagement that's
how much i earned november 2020 from
think
media now what is the revenue split
with creators here's your big question
right
when you enable ads and you're a part of
the ypp
you think about that cpm number that
bigger number
google's revenue share it's a 45 55
split so google takes 45 percent of
youtube advertising
and you get 55 so if there was a hundred
dollars
google's working with dove
soap and they sell an ad on your video
or a cluster of videos
and dove pays google a hundred dollars
and google gives you 55 and they keep
45.
you could let me know in the comments if
you think that's fair and if you think
youtube taking a split is fair in my
opinion
i mean they give you youtube for free to
use they have the distribution they
built the infrastructure
so it is what it is but that's the split
and what you're getting again is what's
left over after that advertising
now i believe obviously this is an
article from investopedia.com
but i haven't seen google review this
and revealed this anywhere publicly so i
also think this could change
you know this is just kind of a known
amount but maybe depends on the channel
and remember it's their will to say hey
we want to change it
we want to keep more and by the way they
might need to like i don't know they're
doing pretty well they're listing crazy
profits
they're up like 5 billion up like 30
over last year right now
google and youtube are doing real well
but they can always change things to
affect
please show shareholders hire new
employees scale whatever it is they need
to do right
because keep in mind also that running
this program
is freaking insane the amount of and
they keep throwing more people at it and
they don't even have near enough people
to review content to see if videos are
advertising compliant or if they got
demonetized for the wrong reasons
they are throwing thousands and
thousands of people at it they probably
need to throw
a quarter million people at it so
there's there's this ever-growing
multi-dimensional conversation happening
around this there's you the creator
me the creator but there's a lot of
things that play
but it's also a fact that google is
doing very well as we can see
so memberships
this one really lean in for this youtube
takes 30
of a channel membership giving creators
70
so you're allowed to affect how much
people pay per month i think it could be
a dollar
uh five is kind of an average now keep
in mind twitch
is 50 50. all right so that's
interesting a 50
split between creators and the company
if they if you have a
dollar tag on you know membership on
your on your site
so it's kind of nice that you get 70
percent in my opinion that's still a
whole lot
so let's say you charge people 10 a
month
to become a member of your channel
you're further down the road you've
thought about different premium
content exclusive content you're going
to give them when you're a channel
member you get things like stickers and
things like that
a pr channel member community tab but i
think the biggest thing you can do
is exclusive q a or exclusive training
or early like
things to really make it worth what
they're investing in and
some people want to just support the
channel and some people want the premium
content
but all that said if it's ten dollars
youtube's gonna take three
and you're gonna keep seven now we
actually have a membership
program for those that wanna learn the
business side
of this whole thing we have video
ranking academies like the youtube side
sort of like the first steps
first four steps of our 10 steps that we
teach people to really make this a
living
that's mastering youtube the second six
steps we go over in what's called inner
circle
and that's like mastering the whole
business side it's like the iceberg
youtube is like the tip of the iceberg
but underneath it is like
build an email list set up your company
um learn
and master modern marketing and all
these other things but
now we host it off of youtube and we pay
for software
called kajabi but
they don't take a percent of anything so
we just have to we pay to use the
software
and besides fees which in every case
there might be transaction fees apple
pay fees
you know one two percent of whatever
transaction fees we pay that too using
stripe so we pay like less than two
percent
for the transaction but we keep nearly
then about 98 so if you think about that
at scale let's say you got a thousand
members at ten dollars a month
that would be ten thousand dollars a
month youtube would take
three thousand dollars you'd keep seven
thousand dollars if you set it up off of
youtube
you'd keep 98 percent however
and this is where you need to make your
decisions as you're building your brand
and thinking about your future
youtube's so integrated maybe somebody
doesn't want to go somewhere else maybe
they want to just live on youtube maybe
they want the ease of use
maybe you don't want to pay for another
software service especially if you're a
creator that's starting this isn't going
to cost you anything
once you hit this threshold so even if
it's a place you start and you move
later
you don't have to think like i'm paying
for separate software i hope i hit
enough members
again like what's kind of nice is
actually when you're on the smaller side
your youtube's taking the risk or
they're taking all the heavy lifting
and why wouldn't you give them 30 but
what i would say is if you're further
along let's say you're doing
100 000 a year from a channel membership
situation
youtube would take 30 000 of those
dollars leaving you with 70. you might
want to start you know considering your
decisions at that level so
um let me know if this is valuable
information and if you do appreciate and
you've been getting value out of this
video
um it would mean the world to me if you
hit the like button and give me some
feedback what else do you want to know
and what questions do you have
for future videos regarding channel
memberships memberships building your
business
youtube ad revenue next super chat
how much does youtube take from super
chat they take 30
so i want to thank you for the super
chats that have came in when i was
recording this live
and and if you drop a
10 super chat right now three dollars
will go to youtube
right and seven will go to think media
and think marketing
and this is not considering any apple
service fees tax mcm
cuts et cetera so it's just kind of the
raw numbers and super chats can be
anywhere from one dollar to 500
okay now to turn on
monetizations uh options each one gets
kind of turned on
uniquely or specifically so let me give
you an example if you want to turn on
super chats
um you need a thousand subscribers
you're already a member of the youtube
partner program
you're in one of the right countries and
i actually
just let's see this um when
we'll talk about this a little bit later
kids content
if you have your audience set for made
for kids
then it might restrict super chats or it
will
if a certain video is made for kids it
will probably restrict super chats it
kind of makes sense because if a kid is
watching that how in the world
are they actually i mean it's probably
their parents credit card you know
you paying you money with super stickers
and super chats
so that's a heads up if you have content
made for kids and we'll touch that on
that later
but i actually just turned it on on
think marketing
it wasn't even turned on yet as i
mentioned this is a new channel
this year okay and so
uh you can see if you go to your
monetizations tab you start getting
new options and new boxes video
advertising that's your ypp
your merchandise shelf that you can
start building out
your super chats and you also have your
let me see
your memberships that you can set up so
i clicked on
super chats i click get started okay
and i went over to supers up top you can
see that there so you've got merchandise
membership supers
and then it opened up a pro a commerce
product addendum this is like a terms of
service
see this so you scroll through this
whole thing
i then entered my name my email and
something else
and boom think marketing
was had super chats turned on and people
were able to give today
in super chats for the first time pretty
cool and so
um then you have this little knob where
you can disable it on and off
now if you want to just flip a switch
but now whenever we go live for coffee
with cannel
or think marketing live with heather
taurus
super chats can come in and one of the
ways we'll use that in the future
is if you give a super chat maybe then
it'll just put you to the front of the
line for q
a or doing channel reviews or something
like that so those are ideas if you
could think about ways to include that
in
how you monetize key is once you even
hit the threshold like we have
on this channel you then go into and you
can see these tabs
merchandise membership supers giving and
i think giving is youtube allowing you
to partner with different non-profits
and eventually that brand connect tab
will show up
and so as you evolve and getting
subscribers and watch time
and as your channel grows there might be
more features and then as youtube
evolves they might bolt on more features
and more ways for you to earn money
all right couple new youtube
monetization updates one of the huge
things that happened recently
was beginning in january 2020 youtube
dramatically curtailed the data
collected for videos marked for made for
kids
um and they disabled a lot of features
if videos were targeting kids
limiting ads for kids and so this is why
in each one of your videos and live
streams
you need to be selecting unless you you
can select this at a channel level
and also at an individual video level
you could say yes it's made for kids or
no it's not made for kids not the topic
of this video
but if it's not made for kids it's not
made for kids it's not
could it be watched by kids you should
take that into consideration
but did you make the kit man there's no
way for
for uh kids focus creators to make money
that is not true
and i'll show you in a second how
actually still the top earning creators
are making content for kids it just made
the ads less specific specific but
brands could still advertise
on a channel on a macro it had a lot
more to do with the detail
of ads and the fact that like when
youtube follows you around
it's like collecting your watch time
history you know deciding what to
recommend to you and so it's like
kappa said you can't collect all that
data people can still advertise
on the videos in a broad sense just in a
less granular sense and this has been an
evolving topic
so that's something to know about and
then lately or most
recently youtube made a massive this is
huge friends lean in
youtube will now show ads on all videos
even if creators don't want them
and youtube's going to run ads on
smaller creators videos without
paying them so there's a lot of outrage
in the community of
people that were like what the heck
because it's kind of like a double
whammy to small creators number one you
actually may opt
to not turn ads even on because you'd
rather
win influence before you build your
income that's what we did on all of our
channels and my whole journey
i've withheld turning on monetization
right from the start
because we've been more interested in
building our brand
than turning on eventually we turn it on
but it's like if nobody knows you yet
what's five cents on a youtube ad
compared to potentially building a bond
different people have different opinions
but now you have no choice
so whether you could either turn ads on
or not but the double whammy
is that you don't even get a cut
you know when you're part of the ypp you
get 55 in this case
youtube's keeping 100 this shows you
that youtube can do whatever they want
whenever they want
now to put some things into perspective
on this
um uh they are just rolling this out and
testing this does not mean that ads will
be playing on your videos if you're not
a part of the youtube partner program
they're rolling it out and testing
that's how youtube does things they roll
out features on some channels
some videos and they test it so we'll
see where this goes
and on the other hand this is
uh why it's important to have multiple
streams of income
and what i also think and we're going to
be making a concerted effort
here at think media and think marketing
to create some content to help you reach
that 1 000 subscriber threshold
and 4 000 hour watch time very
specifically because i want the ypp
money to go directly to you
i know some business owners and
entrepreneurs that even if they were
eligible for the ypp
they didn't want to do it because the
business model they have the products
and the services they have to sell
so far outra way adsense they'd rather
get you right into the content
help you serve you and give you a chance
to do business with them rather than
being up to interrupted with an ad first
but those days are gone
because now youtube has the right to
put ads on regardless therefore it is my
opinion that all of us
should sprint to be a part of the ypp no
matter what so at least we can all
collect
that 55 percent as well as develop
multiple streams of income
don't stress in the short term although
i know this is kind of crazy
but because what can you do other than
just create content keep building
get that a thousand subscribers keep
building towards the uh watch time hours
but regardless youtube is a free
platform and like
most platforms whether it's a blog an
audio platform
ads display ads play you use instagram
for free people are swiping they see
your content and they see a sponsored
post
they're gonna see ads youtube is just
kind of deciding to
make even more money by just starting to
roll out ads across
content that is advertiser friendly
meets policies but it's not part of the
ypp yet
and it's out of your control what you
can control
is the next video you create as your
strategy is how quickly you're focusing
on growing
and is creating multiple streams of
revenue which again if you want to learn
more about that
don't miss our updated web class
link in the description at
thinkmasterclass.com
so how much are creators earning how
much are creators
earning with the ypp here's some recent
stats of some of the top channels
so ryan's toy world right
ryan's world has 25 million subscribers
and they have him listed as earning 26
million dollars in a year
now i believe these stats i it may be an
aggregate of what they think he makes
from brand deals and this that and the
other thing
but some of these examples this is
talking just adsense meaning just the
youtube partner program
because there's no way they could know
what endorsements
brand deals and the full width of
everything else that they're doing
so i want you to notice this ryan's a
kid's channel
he unboxes toys plays games and does
quizzes and puzzles to entertain kids
so and he's crushing so if you no matter
who your content is targeted for
check the right box and know that you
can grow and still
make a lot of money with the ypp even if
you have kids content
notice this that he's also expanded to
eight other channels
making ryan's world a small empire
second dude perfect 20 million dollars
uh
anastasia radzin i'm not gonna try to
say the last name somebody help me
uh 18 million a five-year-old russian
girl so clearly
an adult had to sign up for the adsense
program
55.6 million followers
and 18 million dollars in a year she has
120 million followers across
six channels so a lot of the people that
really start to build big influence and
focus heavily on
youtube's partner program the ypp
start to expand into multiple channels
to just bring in a windfall
of revenue from all of that viewership
giving people more content
more things to look at jeffree star uh
or rhett and link at four
17.5 million and then jeffree star
17 million um
and it says with millions of follow and
now millions of followers and his own
cosmetics line
jeffree star makes significantly more
from his cosmetics line
than he does from his youtube ads but 17
million a year could you live on that
let me know
in the comments if you could live on 17
million in a year
um okay so check this out
though this whole industry friends is
just getting started and it's going
crazy
so there's a really in-depth article
that just came out
that did a deep dive study that
discovered that two million creators are
making six-figure incomes on youtube
instagram and twitch
globally and i want you to see this so
it revealed
that there are over 2 million
professional creators
now this is a cross platform and there's
46.7
amateur creators in the world at the
time of recording this
going into 2021 at the beginning there
are now over 50 million content creators
1 million professional creators on
youtube and 12 million
amateur creators on youtube this has
become the fastest
growing type of small business out of
all of them right
now here's what's shocking to me their
definition
of a professional creator in this study
was they said what a professional
creator is a creator that's full-time
and for that creator to be full-time
that means they're earning a six-figure
salary
they're making at least six failures six
figures so i about spit out my
uh you know alkaline water because i was
like since when
did you need to make six figures to be
full-time
i moved to vegas with my wife sonia and
our two chihuahuas
to work at a church for 42 000
a year and in vegas cost of living i
felt like we were living like
kings like we 42 grand a year in vegas
back in
2010 freaking i felt like the
the prince of egypt like i was just
and so i think it's interesting that
to be considered professional that's a
staggering number
and i want to encourage you by how
much opportunity there is if a million
creators because i know you're like well
there's so much competition
my friends look at how many people are
actually doing so well put that in
perspective
a million creators are earning over six
figures
thousands are earning seven figures on
just youtube
and you can see this chart right there's
other platforms but
let's look at that 12 million youtube
creator number
that means those critters some are
earning nothing right they're just
getting started
but some are earning hundreds a year or
a month
some are earning thousands and some are
earning multiple thousands and what i
want you to hear is going into 2021 and
what this deep dive signal file
fire article revealed is that this
creator economy
is gonna double over the next few years
meaning creators
making this a full-time living a
full-time income so out of that 12
million creators
millions are earning hundreds a year
millions are earning
thousands a year an extra five grand a
year an extra 12 000 a year
and millions are earning high fig high
five figures 45 grand
55 grand 68 000 and there's
so much freaking opportunity in this
space i'm not trying to over hype it
to say like it's just so easy like you
shoot one video on your webcam
without trying and a windfall of money
goes into your bank account this stuff
takes work it takes discipline it takes
strategy it takes focus
but this is a real this is the fastest
growing small business type
and it is established it's tried and
true
and there's ways to navigate this is the
mission of think media and think
marketing
we want to help 10 000 just 10 000
of those 12 million become full-time
creators
we want to help 10 000 purpose-driven
people create a full-time living
doing what they love while making a
difference in the world with online
video
i don't even define that by six figures
because i know that you can live
the median household income in america
which is an incredible incredible
incredible place to live
is like 55 58 000.
so how much opportunity is in that red
12 million and furthermore
how much opportunities there is on even
these other platforms
you youtube my friends is just getting
started the creator economy
is just getting started it's reached a
pretty massive level
with this many content creators but this
article
very soberly and with much clarity and
zero hype
broke down how the industry whether it's
software companies
whether it's camera companies whether
it's creators themselves whether it's
finance companies helping creators
finance projects how people are viewing
creators like startups
this is the new era friend this is the
future
and i know if you're subscribed to think
media think marketing that
you're a part of that journey and maybe
this is what you want to build so let me
know
what is your ambition with youtube what
is it that what's your goal with youtube
what is it that you want to build do you
want to go full time are you already
part-time or full-time
have you already started earning money
let me know um and are you a part of the
ypp are you already a part of the
youtube partner program have you learned
anything
in regards to the ypp and what questions
do you have about monetization
if you've been getting value out of this
how youtube works series it would mean
the world to me
if you hit the like button but also let
me know what other questions you have
what do you want me to cover
in future videos i'll hit a few of the
frequently asked questions and questions
that are coming in now
but as a final reminder today's episode
is brought to you by the tube
starter kit.com
where you can get a jump start best deal
we've done of the whole year
ninety percent off uh you can grab the
special for a limited time if you go to
tubestarterkit.com
there may be some other special but it
won't be at this holiday discounted
price
of just 37 that's 90 off link in the
description down below
these are the key elements get your
thumbnails right so you can get that
click through
save money on gear get make the right
video ideas to grow your channel
get the 51 money making video ideas tons
of video ideas
outside of the ypp so no matter what
size your channel is at
you need money for the mission a lot of
really cool resources go to
tubestarterkit.com
to learn more about that now
tate said my question is after you're
part of the ypp
do you just turn on all forms of ads i
know it's per
personal preference but i'm curious
about your different
strategies great question so for me
and for the think media team we turn on
pretty much
all forms we do not turn on sponsored
cards because i believe that could click
people away from the video
um we turn on the overlay ads the
skippable and non-skippable
and you have to remember just because
you turn them on does not mean that the
ad is going to play
okay it just means that youtube may play
it
i actually do think it is personal
preference tate but i actually think
there's
some wisdom in just turning them all on
because youtube although they might
overdo it
they don't want to ruin their user
experience so again just because you
turn them all on
doesn't mean that they're going to show
when you turn them all on you're giving
youtube the permission
to try to maximize viewer satisfaction
and earnings because they want ads to
play they're giving you a cut and
they're keeping a cut
and you cannot turn on
the after or during uh ads
if the video is less than eight minutes
but if it's
longer than eight minutes um i turn them
all on as well
and again i'm gonna trust youtube to
play
uh i uh whatever ads are gonna play and
here's the thing
if someone um i i know
things can be hard times can be hard but
i think everyone should pay for youtube
red so you don't have to see or youtube
premium
so you can see this video is 23 minutes
i've got during and after and i
allow youtube to manage those mid rolls
you're able to add particular ad breaks
and whatnot
i've done that at certain times in
multi-part videos
but these days we just check all the
boxes
except for sponsored cards and let
youtube do
their thing sometimes someone goes i saw
a bunch of ads and i'm like
get youtube premium or i i'm trying to
bring as much valuable content to you
and if you don't want to pay for youtube
premium
or something else or like be a part of
another thing then this is what you get
is ads because
this is how we're able to not just
sustain think media this is not just
sean cannell
this is a team of 12 people this is a
whole media company that is here to
serve you and help you reach your goals
so that's our philosophy i would love to
know your philosophy and tell me in the
comments
do you think you're seeing too many ads
would you hesitate from checking some of
those boxes
do you think i'm crazy for turning on
all those boxes let me know george
would it be smart to wait until you've
reached about two to three thousand subs
before applying
there's no reason to wait if you want to
be a part of the
the ypp as soon as you hit the
eligibility requirements
and from my experience reaching 1 000
subscribers
is much easier than reaching 4000 hours
of watch time that takes a long time
it's a lot of consumption we'll be
talking about some strategies in future
videos
about how i would shorten that path and
we're going to do some dedicated content
on that
jeffrey what's your opinion of mid roll
again
i think that um i know that some people
who reply
solely on the ypp they is
they live off it like they actually they
need it like sometimes i know people
that
that'll smash multiple like three four
five ads manually as mid rolls in their
videos
if people really want your content and
they want to wait to the end
again we could be so critical of youtube
creators but i don't know if you've
watched
freaking hulu lately even if you pay for
the nice hulu but you get on one of
those videos that's like playing an ad
i'm not saying it's a good thing
sometimes i was watching the swamp thing
with my wife sonia and i was like i
can't even watch the show
we've watched more ads not only that
they're the same ad like every single
time it's like
a day you're like dude give me a break
and i'm like and i pay for hulu premium
like what is happening
so i do think it absolutely could
um you know uh
be overdone and it depends on your over
overall business and strategies
at this point we check the box i don't
know how many play
it depends on how long the video is
listen i quote youtube
by default mid-rolls will be placed at
natural break points to balance the
viewer experience and create a revenue
so it's natural break points they're
going to figure it out they're trying to
balance the viewer experience and then
balance creator revenue
so i leave it up to them some people
depend on ypp
they go more hardcore and i'd love your
opinion on what you think about that
influential finance can you turn ads
off if monetized my understanding
is you could uncheck all of these boxes
but now with youtube's recent updates
they might show ads regardless and if
you're part of the ypp if they forced
ads on your videos you would get a cut
that's a developing story and
in the past some entrepreneurs would
just say i don't want to mess with them
i want to turn them off
it's like youtube if you're advertiser
friendly wants the freedom to put ads on
your videos so if they're going to do it
no matter what
in my opinion i'd rather take obviously
the revenue
so that youtube doesn't take 100 and i
get zero i'd rather them take their 45
and my 55.
if that makes sense this is the
developing story in terms of again
you're part of the ypp
um and uh it's you know
evolving and so uh we'll see what
happens with them
quote unquote you know forcing ads not
just on smaller creators but on all
channels and all videos
if you got like uh if you got value out
of today's coffee with channel hit
like we've been in a deep dive uh
episode here
and let me know if you've been enjoying
this uh series
and i just want to say i appreciate you
so much click or tap the screen right
now to go watch
part one and two in this series because
it's all about how youtube works
if you love this video you're gonna love
those videos as well i appreciate you so
much grateful for you
and i will see you in the next coffee
with kennel peace